Pittsburgh will get to it clear forward for
Vinny henrosa henrosa gets to the slot and
shot right through R makes the save and closes
the wickets on that pretty short morning skate
portion of the talk to the coach after the
penguin skate now stall the former penguin's
Choice gets that out in front martinook puts
one and hits off the post I no pun intended
I left get that go in one ear and out the other
absolutely partner is Carolina trying to change
the score right now out in front to AO Second
Chance J just robs him Carolina keeping the
pressure on Shan shot that goes off the crossbar
and deflects out of play so the good here in the
first period heck of a look from Jarvis to
AO AO isn't able to take advantage of the
open portion of the net because of the last
minute back check from well that could have
been a penalty that's underneath but it's on
the hands but jar makes two excellent trying
to motor through the middle of the ice Carolina
stops his progress Puck will find n lari Crosby
against Carolina's fourth line and third defensive
pairing now a shot to the side of an net they'll
score and right on Q Sydney Crosby side of the
net back hands one in this game is so much about
matchups this is the first time that Crosby has
been out against a different defensive pairing
than Shay and pesi you know they're licking their
chops you get a tip at the hash marks gel gets it
through you get the tip from machari it's a bounce
okay the tip from machari ends up just about going
five on Crosby now looking for AO that pass is
interrupted a minute left here in the period now
a loose Puck and it's going to be rust coming in
on Ron goes for it back in he hits the post rust
had Ron beat and he hit the post opportunity
for Riley Smith but he fans on that chance and
the canes play this up the boards Terra vinan
looking to drop it back Shay with it his shot
and a big save made by jar and Pittsburgh wants
to turn it the other way Riley Smith Smith he'll
drop it back and a chance here for the Penguins
to work a little magic going across Smith worked
around no opportunity there zah Horna got to it
now it's intercepted good play by pesi zah Horna
will get to it now out in front and R up oh mercy
ATI robbing Riley Smith battling against Sydney
Crosby from his days in Washington's played 42
times in a r Sebastian Alo they wanted to stay
offside but he tagged himself up and the other
thing is AO comes up with a intercept drop this
one back Jarvis ter oh they score Tick T tied
Carolina Sebastian AO buries it his fifth of the
Year love the way they stacked up AO and Company
in the neutral zone and while Terra has found the
back of the net his playmaking has been dormant
well it wasn't here Jarvis drops it to him in a
brilliant pass and the guy that stacked up the
neutral zone getss himself to a soft area knows
table will find him and ties the hockey game
not to the degree that shaded on the open net
now nus and the canes coming in NES trying to go
across oh and a huge save getting it Cross by jar
Pittsburgh will get to that good for checking
pressure from Jarvis forcing the turnover from
mang out in front Jarvis his shot and somehow
jar got a piece on that that was going to the
back back of the net welcome to the 2023 24 season
the playmaker that is ter table tabin wow what a
save by jar he recognizes the pass is coming The
KES put the defensive pairing back out there late
here on this power play with slaven Puck off
the back of the net for swet nikov he'll send
this back up top slaven burn shete scores on the
power [Applause] play Feel the burn 2-1 Carolina
Ron a short-handed Breakaway save now Burns looped
himself from the goal line eventually gets himself
in a onetime position and just fires it achari I
think prevents jari from getting a good look at
it n stick was also on the way in COD KMI here's
n is calling for it n is trying to play a little
one one onone across for snov he scores that's
the magic spetch nikov first of the year and
Carolina goes up 3-1 sure look to be on side
for me it's going to be close I'm sure that's
what Pittsburgh is looking at cross- siiz pass
on the tape with Pace from poam to NES and NIS
puts it in a spot where spech nikov looks anything
but like a guy that hasn't scored this year here
beating jar High to the blocker waiting to see
if Pittsburgh is going to challenge this there
right in front of their bench as to whether
or not NIS was on [Applause] side TJ luxmore
after coaches challenge the play was determined
to be offside at 11:33 we have no goal and out
the Kane Zone it goes but just momentarily now a
chance flinging the defenses Carlson and RTO makes
the save rebound still available still have to
play through penalty coming up to the hurricanes
on that try now this is loaded up out in front
though score bouncing Puck will be settled down
and hammered home penalty shot coming we won't
know what that was going to be boy I have one
question now Crosby gets his second Bounce by
being in proximity to the net very similar spot
to taking advantage of an achari tip that was
off the Target and scoring in the first period
would you ever see a potential challenge here for
Brad bremore that Crosby High stick that puck on
the goal line that is something that you can't
challenge when he was initially on the goal line
and it's not about the crossbar being looked in as
we get a good look at Terra and Terra with a steel
out in front for Jarvis he chips it just wide he
couldn't get an opportunity to get the full stick
on it now AO keeps it in Back to the point worked
across it's slaven slaven out front they score set
Jarvis deflects it home and Carolina gets the
lead back it's 3-2 the guy that just became the
all-time leader and assists in hardford Carolina
history just added another dazzling distribution
of the puck moment to his career in game number
for 601 Jarvis won a battle with physicality to
keep the for check alive on the wall and then
got to the front of the net AO is in the front
of the net Ricard Raquel with speed he'll lay
this off for Malin Malin throws a back in up
front oh R again gets across and robs Riley
Smith even Leo Messi would probably enjoy this
save moving one way flashing out that toe
the other way bang he'll throw it all the
way up as Crosby tried to fly the Zone the
puck will be played around by R and now it
finds terrain to AO empty net taking Target
Bingo Seth Jarvis is second of the game ice
is this one and the hurricanes have a 4-2
lead so often talk about Carolina playing
quick offensively they have really play
quick defensively as this hockey game is
worn along puts one on Shar and this game
is over Carolina battled some adversity
and they find a way to get a 4-2 win over
Metro division fo Pittsburgh here tonight